Of wisecrack Michael, here to talk about everyone's favorite Yuletide, underdog,
or, uh, under deer that's right.
Rudolph Sansa's red nose minion who was best memorialized in that 1964,
stop motion, animated special.
It's a heartwarming depiction of our scrappy little friend finding acceptance in
his community despite being a bioluminescent freak.
But what if the movie can accidentally teach us about the dystopia of modern
life.
Right?
Ruin your childhood in this wisecrack addition on the philosophy of Rudolph the
Red-Nosed reindeer. And of course, spoilers ahead.
Before we get too deep into the world of stop motion, holiday cinema,
I wanted to take a second to talk about my favorite Island of misfit toys,
the wisecrack Patrion.
It's a community of folks who have no problem finding the deepest of meanings in
the weirdest of places.
Not to mention you get to watch all of our videos early and without ads.
You also get exclusive access to the wisecrack discord,
where you can connect with like-minded folks and even shared takes with
wisecrack, host and writers. To give you a free preview.
Here are some of my hot takes on Christmas movies.
Diehard doesn't actually count as a Christmas movie,
but in Bruge absolutely does for Christmases.
It's an underrated classic exploring the fluidity of the American family.
The night before is a great movie to watch with your grandparents and or young
children and home alone. Joe Pesci is actually the good guy.
And until Jeff Bridges plays Santa in a movie,
I'm not interested in any cinematic representations of Kris Kringle for takes
like these and ones that are even worse. Go to
patrion.com/wisecrack and joined today. Memberships start at just $2.
That's the holiday gift you deserve to give yourself so going to
patrion.com/wisecrack today. Now back to the show,
but first a quick recap,
Rudolph follows the adventures of the eponymous reindeer who was born with one
very prominent trait.
He's got a shiny nose, shiny I'd even say a glow.
That had been celebrated for his gift.
Rudolph receives a crash course in feeling ashamed of his body,
taught by his own father.
You're like it and where it is,
there are more important things in comfort.
Rudolph is instructed to hide his shame,
but of course you can't keep an incandescent nose hidden for long.
Once its cover is blown.
Our hero finds himself ruthlessly mocked to the point where he enters a
self-imposed exile on the road,
Rudolph teams up with a fellow North pole weirdo.
Hermie the elf on their journey. The, to meet the prospector Yukon,
Cornelius narrowly avoid the abominable snow monster and end up at this surreal
place.
The Island of misfit toys eventually though Rudolph realizes that he can't keep
running away from his problems and decides to return home.
The only problem his family has been captured by the abominable snow monster,
but with help from his friends,
Rudolph is able to save his family and live happily ever after. Well,
almost after a last minute snowstorm hits the North pole grounding Santa's
sleigh. It seems like Christmas will be canceled.
Everything is grounded. Oh, the poor.
That is until old Kris Kringle realizes he's got a pair of headlights in the
form of Rudolph.
No, that
wonderful note.
Leads. The team. Santa picks up all the misfit toys and Christmas is saved.
The stories takeaway seems to be bullying people for being different is not
cool. So a case closed, not quite incidentally,
Rudolph is also a weird masterclass and the dystopian reality of what
philosopher Michel Fuko called bio power or bio politics. Basically,
if being in charge used to mean beheading your subjects when they were naughty,
modern government power is about the management of life.
AKA bio politics.
It's about keeping a welfare disease-free population who can show up to work on
time and go fight in a war if you need them to.
But what happens when people resist being managed when they either can't or
won't be good productive citizens enter deviancy or the violation of
social norms. Since that deviance is a threat to the biopolitical order,
it must be policed. Historically,
these deviants were criminal misfits or labeled mad or considered physically
unfit to do the work or unwilling to do the whole be heterosexual and make
babies thing on the flip side of deviancy and file politics is normalization,
reforming,
criminals and sexual deviance and so on so that they can be integrated into
society. Now you might be wondering what this all has to do with Rudolph.
It might seem like a stretch, but throughout it's 15 minute runtime,
almost every single major plot point explores how biopower normalizes and
disciplines, deviance, social norms and Christmas town are pretty simple.
Wake up and do your part to make Christmas happen for the kids. For example,
be an elf making toys and these norms work great for their leaders.
Santa's whose primary aim is, you know, Christmas for whatever reason,
even when the elves aren't on the job,
Santa's ensures that they remain loyal tireless workers by having them
participate in elf practice, which by the way is totally not brainwash.
We worked hard all day.
It doesn't just out there reindeer, for example can fly.
And so Santa has created a regimented training program to take advantage of this
trait.
Our first game is called pickup. We all want to [inaudible].
In the North pole.
It's not crazy to say that a reindeer's whole existence revolves around working
for Santa. Just look at the moment. Rudolph is born.
Well daughter, where's the new member of the family after all,
if he's going to be on my team someday, he'd better get to know me. But.
What happens when someone deviates from the norm take Hermie Rudolph's El friend
who would rather be a dentist than a Toysmith for whatever reason,
dentistry isn't exactly considered a social utility in the North pole.
So he is basically astrocytes from the social order. Rudolph's nose,
isn't a hindrance to his function,
but as physical abnormality gets aggressively policed by his family and his
fellow juvenile reindeer, despite both our heroes,
having very real ways in which they could contribute to society.
They're deemed to have little to no social value because they don't fit in.
It's like he said, I'm never fit in.
In effect Rudolph and Hermie are what scholars, David T. Mitchell and Sharon L.
Snyder would call nonproductive bodies or those who have been shunned largely by
virtue of biological incapacity,
aesthetic non-conformity and or non-normative labor patterns.
And what does the biopolitical state of Christmas town do to nonproductive
bodies?
It expels them or treats them with such hostility that they expelled themselves.
Hermie for example,
leaves after his boss threatens to fire him for giving adult teeth,
they don't even ask the question,
why can't our society handle more Dalton and Rudolph is told that
he's forbidden to practice with other Rangers.
Not you better go home with your folks from non dang.
We won't let Rudolph joining any reindeer games, right?
Did we mention that Santa is kind of a Dick here?
You should be ashamed of your show. Walk up. He had a nice tape.
It's not just Rudolph and Hermie who are expelled from society. In fact,
the outside world is teaming with other nonproductive bodies.
Perhaps nothing embodies this better than the entire Island of misfit toys.
And the platonic ideal of pointless toys job is to bring a child happiness as
such toys who are unable to fill this role are useless and are therefore
Castaway for such trivialities as having the wrong name.
My name is don't kill me, Jack, no jar.
That's why booth. My name is all wrong.
No child wants to play with a Charlie in the bar.
Philosopher, NSL mezze calls this process, biopolitical abandonment,
the process by which people who refuse to conduct themselves properly placed
themselves outside of the population.
And thus are no longer deemed worthy of society's care or protection.
The CoreLogic of biopolitics as cell mezze notes co is not only the
fostering of some forms of life, but the disavowal of others,
even to the point of death like that weird team building exercise.
When you have to pretend you and your coworkers are stuck in a life raft,
then you have to awkwardly decide who doesn't get a life preserver as you sink
to your watery grave. By the only one who did that is weird. Cause I,
I said me and then everyone just got really sad,
but I thought I was taking one for the team. I don't work there anymore.
In the case of the misfit toys,
that means being abandoned to some weird leper colony, but Hey,
Rudolph is about how this stuff is bad.
The film has a happy ending in which everyone apologizes to Rudolph and Hermie
for treating them so poorly. If anything,
Rudolph is the celebration of the things that make us different, right? Well,
yes.
And that makes it even more interesting that's because it only shows us how bio
politics manages deviancy,
but how it can end up incorporating first and foremost,
it's important to note that when Rudolph finally comes back,
nothing is different. He's still the object of scorn.
Hey look, who's back on neon. Now.
The pressing Santa seems to only care about Rudolph's return. And so far,
has it benefits his mission with Rudolph's father out looking for him.
Santa will be down a worker, come Christmas.
Christmas Eve is only two days off without your father.
I'll never be able to get my sleep off the ground.
Maybe most depressingly still Rudolph is only hailed as a hero.
When the very nose that he was vilified for, it becomes socially useful.
Suddenly Rudolph goes from being a non-productive body to being a hero.
I knew that nos would be useful someday. I knew it all wrong.
Information from scorned to misfit to savior of Christmas can best be understood
as a rehabilitation or what Mitchell and Snyder call a productive process of
recovery leading to a return to employment in the activities of civic life.
In other words, rehabilitation amounts to an economic transformation.
And it's one that all the misfits undergo in this film. For example,
you kind of Cornelius claims that he's reformed the now toothless abominable
snowman.
I, for him, this Bumble, he wants a job.
The skirt.
The North.
Now the monster is toothless and capable of being assimilated into the
biopolitical order.
And then there are the misfit toys after Sante confidently promises to find
children who would want to play with them.
Rudolph. I promise as soon as this storm lets up,
I'll find homes for all those misfit toys.
Misfit toys see an elevation in their social status and short because Santa's
decreed it.
So they're wanted again and to such they're reintroduced into society.
Beyond our way. Finally.
There's Hermie who finds himself rehabilitated.
When the head elf apparently realizing the cavities are a thing,
allows him to open his own dental practice.
I bet they set up an appointment for you a week from Fugazi.
Then is the logic of bio politics expelled a nonproductive,
or at least abandoned them. If you can normalize them,
take away their teeth and rough edges so they can become a productive member of
society. However, society defines that,
but biopower is a technology and one that's always shifting. So yes,
your tooth fetish, might've made you a freak a few months ago,
but now that we can put it to use walkable Baird,
the same applies to Rudolph's nose,
which once they realize it can help Santa navigate,
the snowstorm suddenly becomes highly valuable.
It reflects the ongoing process in the real world,
in which behaviors and attributes that were once labeled deviant can be
assimilated into the productive order.
People once thought incorrectly that gay people were a threat to the social
fabric, particularly in the army.
But once the military realized that they could be drone pilots to inclusion
became a strength. And so like Rudolph's red nose,
different categories of so-called deviance be accepted into the social order on
account of their differences.
But what do you guys think is Christmas down actually a utopia where everyone
can contribute with their own unique traits or is this classic Christmas tale
actually a grim demonstration of how biopower functions in the modern world.
Let us know in the comments. Huge,
thanks to our patrons for all your support hit that subscribe button,
like your social worth depends on it.
And don't forget to ring that bell and as always, thanks for watching.
Later,
[inaudible].